[Music]
suspect appears to be smuggling white
lightning repeat suspect appears to be
smuggling white lightning
well in north carolina way back in the
hills
lift my old papi and he sold him some
milk he brew wide lighting until the sun
went down and then he fill up a jug
and he pass it around mighty mighty
pleasing pappy's cow squeezing
shh whoo i'd like that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
several arrests were made as selling raw
milk remains
illegal to this day and somehow our
jails are overcrowded
anyway
well the next time you're out shopping
maybe take a look
some people like fresh food better than
cooked
food sold raw happens all the time
though i'll concede there is a milk that
should be a crime
cloudy for some reason largely
unpleasing
just frightening
in a truly free society there are some
potentially dangerous activities if you
think our jails are crowding maybe we
should be allowing
white lightning
hey what are you arresting me for i made
oat milk
oh come on